Chief Economist of the IMF saying the
fog around the world economic Outlook
has thickened why is that specifically
and he's absolutely correct it has
thickened for three reasons one is
growth is less buoyant
um they are now projecting very muted
economic growth for the next five years
and without growth you get all sorts of
problems the second reason is because of
financial instability we had some
Tremors in the U.S banking system we
were reminded that the system doesn't
adjust easily to higher interest rates
and third they are also worried about
sticky inflation so put all three things
together and we are now driving on quite
a foggy Motorway and why is the UK the
worst of a lot among the major economies
so it's worth of the G7 for this year we
are projected to contract by 0.3 percent
not as bad as they thought three months
ago but still the worst among the G7 as
you point out Mark
um two reasons one is our inflation has
remained much higher than elsewhere and
that impacts people's ability to spend
they have less money to spend and
secondly is we've had much higher energy
prices at elsewhere so these two things
have meant that domestic demand has been
less of a driver of economic growth I
asked because a lot of the factors
causing the UK problems must also be
causing the problems for other major
economies
so some countries are much more robust
think of the US they're energy
independent and they haven't had the
inflation shocked that we've had
um in fact we still have the highest
inflation rate among the G7
um that's one issue and then the second
issue is the ability to rely on the
external world we are still redefining
our external trading relationship after
brexit so we don't have the external
engine that we once had
and the picture on inflation I thought
was better in the sense that you know
it's coming down significantly well we
were told it was coming down
significantly through this year is that
still the case
so inflation will continue to come down
with two really important qualifications
the IMF doesn't think it's going to come
down as quickly as they thought three
months ago and secondly they're starting
to realize that something that you and I
have discussed in the past is that
inflation may end up being sticky that
we may not see see it go back to the two
percent targets the central banks have
it may get sticky another three to four
percent and then there'll be really
difficult decisions to make as to what
do central Bankers do at that stage
right they still think though they do
seem to think that interest rates could
come down quite sharply
they do that surprised me a little bit
because it's inconsistent with some
other parts of their projections I hope
they are right
um I suspect that when we look back
interest rates will not have come down
as fast unless we get into one of their
Dreadful scenarios you know they put a
15 probability of a rather nasty
scenario and if that were to happen that
risk scenario then interest rates would
come down but they would be coming down
for for bad reasons right well they're
not always right are they
um where do you think interest rates
could be at the end of the year
so I think we are going to still see
them go higher in the short term this
will be as early as the beginning of May
with the Federal Reserve I expect they
will hike another quarter of a
percentage points and then central banks
will start to differ the European
Central Bank will continue hiking I
think the FED will take a pause and see
but the FED is telling the markets you
are wrong the markets think that the FED
will start
having interest rates and having a whole
percentage points lower and the FED is
saying no markets that's not going to
happen so it's going to be fascinating
Mark to see who's right the central the
world's most powerful Central Bank or
the markets yeah I mean does the IMF
really matter to the forecast really
matter because as people often say
certainly governments who are on the
sort of receiving end of the forecast
they say well they often get them wrong
so you know I think our forecast as
doing one of three things in general
they either informed the debate
or they influence the debate or they
impose themselves upon the debate
um I think in this case we are somewhere
between inform and influence we're
certainly nowhere near impose this is
very different when the bank of England
came out for example with its forecast
that if we don't do something inflation
goes up to 13 percent
that impose itself on the debate on the
policy debate here at best it's
informing and somewhat influencing the
debate but it's not going beyond that
right well look we only got uh 30
seconds left when do we start pulling
out of this Gloom you were talking in
your first answer about them saying what
five years or so I mean what are your
views on it
so I think they're too pessimistic over
the next five years I think we're gonna
pull out but it's gonna get foggier
before it clears
um and this is a world in which
unfortunately people can make mistakes
so it's really important to have both
financial and human resilience here okay
Muhammad good to talk to you very
interesting thanks very much indeed